so you mentioned that
this simulation that we run over and
over might start
so it's a slow start so do you think uh
how unlikely first of all i don't know
if you think about this kind of stuff
but
how unlikely is step number zero
which is the springing up like the
origin of life on earth
and second how unlikely
is the anything interesting happening
beyond that
sort of like the start that that that
creates
all the rich complexity that we see on
earth today yeah
there are people who are working on
exactly that problem uh
from primordial soup how do you actually
get self-replicating yeah molecules
and they are very close uh with a little
bit of help you can make that happen
um so we
of course we know what we want so they
can set up the conditions and try out
conditions that are
conducive to that uh for evolution to
discover that
that took a long time for us to recreate
it probably won't take that long
and the next steps from there
i think also with some hand-holding i
think we can make that happen
um but if with evolution what was really
fascinating was eventually the
runaway evolution of the brain that
created
humans and created well also other
higher animals
that that was something that happened
really fast and
that's a big question is that something
replicable is that something that
can happen and if it happens does it go
in the same direction
that is a big question to ask even in
computational
terms i think that it's relatively
possible to
come up here create an experiment where
we look at the primordial soup and the
first couple of steps
of multicellular organisms even but to
get something as complex as the brain
we don't quite know the conditions for
that and how to even get started and
whether we can get this kind of runaway
evolution happening
from a detector perspective
if we're observing this evolution what
do you think is the brain what do you
think is the
let's say what is intelligence so in
terms of the thing that makes humans
special we seem to be able to reason
we seem to be able to communicate but
the core of that is this
something in the broad category we might
call intelligence
so uh if you put your computer
scientists at on
is there favorite ways you like to think
about that
question of what is intelligence
well my goal is to create
agents that are that are intelligent
not to define what and and that that is
a way of defining it
and that means that it's some kind of an
um
object or or a program um
that has limited sensory and
effective capabilities interacting with
the world
and then also a mechanism for making
decisions
so with limited abilities like that can
it
survive survival is the simplest goal
but it could
you could also give it other goals can
it multiply can it solve problems that
you give it
and that is quite a bit less than human
intelligence there are
animals would be intelligent of course
with that definition and you might
have even even some other forms of life
even
so what so intelligence in that sense is
a survival
skill uh given resources that you have
and using using your resources so that
you will stay around
you